A cry for help as coastlines of vulnerable island states vanish under rising sea levels…
A distress call as swathes of the ancient ice sheets of Greenland and the Antarctic melt away
and the Arctic sea ice diminishes rapidly.
A white flag as our most emblematic coral reefs, Earth’s single biggest living structure succumb to bleaching.
These are no longer warning shots. These are not signals but symptoms.
Our ocean is suffering some of the most dramatic and damaging effects of climate change.
Greenhouse gas emissions generated by human activity
are causing sea temperatures to rise faster than ever recorded,
destabilising ecosystems and reducing biodiversity.
These same emissions are changing our ocean’s very chemistry.
Increased acidification caused by carbon dioxide
jeopardises whole species of marine life,
including plankton, the very basis of it all.
Absorbing up to 90% of excess greenhouse heat,
our ocean is doing more than its share to help regulate the Earth’s climate
and diminish the effects of climate change.
Now it is our turn to act.
If we do not, extreme weather conditions such as cyclones and tropical storms will only increase,
wreaking havoc in coastline communities and threatening to sweep away vulnerable traditional livelihoods.
So, how will we fight climate change?
How will we mitigate its effects on us,
our islands,
our coasts
and our ocean?